the reason that I became a good
communicator and challenged myself to
become a good communicator was because I
realized if I couldn't communicate well
I couldn't make a good difference how
the great leaders do it is they're just
so comfortable in their own skin if you
want to make yourself articulate which
is a very good idea then not only should
you read but you should write down what
you think want to be happy
build a life not just the business
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believed life and learn how you can
improve your communication skills
okay let's kick it off with way number
one be enthusiastic with Brendon
Burchard enthusiasm I mean look at the
video of me coming out on stage
watch me interact with the audience so
watch me on any of my youtube videos
watch listen to my podcasts hpx podcast
it's like everything that I believe
about HP X which stands for the high
performance experience is about the
enthusiasm and zest we must have for
life or that we must generate and create
and so I'm just enthusiastic about stage
even if I'm scared even haven't worried
even I'm concerned and I mean certainly
walking out in front of thousands of
people wasn't my original jam I mean I I
was that person who was not good at that
did not have skill not and did not want
to do that but the reason that I became
a good communicator and challenged
myself to become a good communicator was
because I realized if I couldn't
communicate well I couldn't make a good
difference if you don't teach yourself
train yourself put yourself in those
situations where you become a better
speaker a better communicator or a
better leader then how are you ever
gonna change the world how are we ever
gonna do something that you feel is like
significant and important so I trained
myself to do that so I make sure that
I'm enthusiastic for my topic and my
mission and my purpose when I go out on
that stage
even if inside I feel anxiety I feel
like I don't know if I'm gonna do a good
job those things listen when your fear
becomes secondary to your enthusiasm for
your purpose that's when everything
changes
there's a life truth coming my friend
Evan Carmichael look listen humans are
built to serve some people are built to
serve the world others want to serve the
25 people closest to them but neither
case humans are building serve so if
you're not happy right now is because
you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book this is so
inspiring to remind you that we're all
here to contribute to make a difference
to make an impact and this is your field
guide for that way number two be a
masterful listener with Robin Sharma
second element in terms of how legendary
leaders speak is their masterful
listeners another gargantuan competitive
advantage how the great leaders do it is
they're just so comfortable in their own
skin they're if they've worked on their
ego so much they've turned down the
volume most people's idea of listening
is waiting until the other person has
finished talking so they can start their
own monologue I can't tell you how many
times I'll have a walk with someone I
love walking meetings one hour walks I
learned from Steve Jobs and through the
entire walk they're just sharing their
story and they're sharing where they're
at and they're sharing their
frustrations and they're sharing their
insecurities and they haven't asked me a
single question and I'm happy to help
I'm happy to listen someone asked me the
other night
oh you know when that happens what do
you do and I say you know what most
people have a deep need to be heard and
someone who talks and talks and talks
and talks is generally a child who had
parents who didn't give them a lot of
time and they didn't give him a lot of
attention and they certainly didn't give
them very much listening and so adults
are nothing more than deteriorated
children and adults are often children
grown up bodies and I see that and I
simply am very happy to be a listening
ear for them I'm very happy to give them
the listening
they are longing for and I just feel in
that hour I can be an instrument of
service to them and helpful to them by
listening point I'm trying to help you
calibrate and hardwire in is a daily
protocol be one of the rare air few one
of the top 5% leaders on the planet who
really have dialed in to listening not
from your head but from your heart
listening at a cellular level and here's
the thing when you do that for your team
they grow bigger right in front of you
and the real job of a leader is to grow
people real job of a leader is to build
more leaders real job of a leader is to
leave a blazing trail of epic producers
behind you that's when you know that
you're leading versus following so get
seriously genius at listening way number
three focus on your audience with Dan
Locke I used to get nervous when I walk
up to the stage when all I could focus
on it's me I was so concerned about what
people think what do I do I do I sound
professional what they understand my
accent to make me sure I I cover every
point I want to cover am I telling that
story perfectly
do I sound smart do I look good
whenever you are in front of an audience
and you focus on yourself me me me me me
me me how people perceive you you will
get nervous because you are afraid of
being judged when I shift the focus from
do I sound smart do I look good
do I sound good when I just forget all
that and throw that out the window and I
100% focus on my audience how could I
change their life how can i impact them
how can I make sure they walk away with
value the minute I do that not focusing
on myself or focusing on them the
nervousness disappears it's gone very
very simple because it's all about them
it is my hand in my pocket
am I not know
well you know standing in the right
space am i walking back and forth am i
am i doing the right gesture
forget all that when you forget order
you can connect and when you connect
with the audience
you're not nervous because you can all
you care it's about them you don't care
about how you look anymore you don't
care if you sound so smart no you just
focus on them no more their business we
number four practice more with Jordan
Peterson I'm incredibly nervous to talk
in front of you because you've got to be
one of the most formidable people that
I've ever heard of or ever listened to
her ever seen so my question is again
you're one of the best communicators
that I've ever listened to if I could be
half as good at you or at communicating
as you are I would be set how can I
teach myself to do that practice you
know really like well there's a couple
of things is helps to read a lot it
really helps to write so if you want to
make yourself articulate which is a very
good idea then not only should you read
but you should write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day 15 minutes maybe you could
steal 15 minutes and do it every day but
if you do that for ten years you really
straighten out your thinking if you're
gonna speak effectively you have to know
way more than you're talking about you
know so if you this is often difficult
for beginning lecturers at university
because they'll do a lecture on a topic
but they only know as much as they're
saying in the lecture and they get kind
of stuck to their notes because of it
but you want to know ten times as much
as you are saying in the lecture and
then you can specify a stepping path
through it and elaborate with the other
things that you know but to do that you
have to do a lot of reading but you also
have to do a lot of reading because
that's where the synthesize that's where
the synthesizing comes so that's on the
input side and then on the output side
well there's some tricks techniques
let's say is like if you're speaking in
front of a group you are not delivering
a talk to
group that's not what you're doing the
talk isn't a package thing that you
present to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals and you
talk to them so when I talk to a group I
always talk to people one at a time and
that makes it easier to because you know
how to talk to a person it's like can
you talk to a thousand people well
probably not because it's too
intimidating
but there isn't a thousand people there
there's a thousand individuals and so
you just look at an individual and you
say something and you can tell if
they're engaged they look confused or
they look interested or they look angry
or they look bored or maybe they're
asleep in which case you look at someone
else and they give you feedback about
how you're doing and so one thing is to
to have something to say yeah but the
next thing is pay attention to who
you're talking to because unless you're
very badly socialized and that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know and well I mean I don't
know you very well but at first but on
first sight you know you're doing fine
so the probability that if you pay
attention to the individuals that you're
talking to that your natural wealth of
social skill will manifest itself is
extremely high and so you don't deliver
a talk to an audience that's a really
bad way of thinking about you're
actually engaged in a conversation with
an audience even if they're not talking
they're nodding and shifting position
and you know looking like this or and
you can you can pull that in and and and
use it to govern the level at which
you're addressing the entire audience so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could but your that to some degree there
isn't anything that you can possibly
this is the whole point of a liberal
education there isn't anything that you
can possibly do that makes you more
competent in everything you do than to
learn how to communicate I don't care if
you're gonna be a carpenter I mean being
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like ten times better
as a carpenter so the and this is
something that the liberal arts colleges
I think I don't know if they've
forgotten it but they don't do a very
good job of marketing it's like what's
the use of a bachelor's degree Bachelor
of Arts it's like well you can think you
can write you can speak you've read
something it's like the economic value
that is incalculable the people that
I've watched in my life would be
spectacular ly successful are they have
skills clearly that that's a minimum
precondition but they're also very very
good at articulating themselves and so
whenever they negotiate they're
successful well that's kind of like the
definition of success in life right you
negotiate and you're six doesn't mean
you win because if you're a good
negotiator if you're really good
negotiator everybody walks away from the
negotiation thrilled and so then people
line up to do things with you so and
that's all that's all dependent on your
ability to communicate so practice
anyway number five the last one before a
very special bonus clip is tell great
stories with Patrick big David sometime
when I get asked to speak for three
hours and they want to do Q&A that's a
different talk than it is from an hour
to just give a presentation than it is
from hey can you give a ten minute talk
here then a five minute talk if I'm
asked to talk five minutes on TV or on
whatever it is that I'm speaking for
five minutes
I'm here's a point here's a story done
let me tell you about what's going on
over here here's the conditions that
we're looking at right now
that I thought that uh here's what I
think we need to consider change into
and here's what I believe will be the
solution let me tell you why I believe
this I remember one was 1992 and both
story okay story so get into your story
when you want it to make your point tell
story somebody who is very good at
making stories and figuring out ways for
me to take a metaphor or an analogy that
I can excite that makes that makes sense
I get it I got it I respond to that and
most people respond to that as well
if you're telling your story now I've
got a special bonus skip from gray
Cardone on how to speak with authority
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
how will you be more enthusiastic in
your communication number two how will
you be a better listener in your next
presentation and number three how can
you better focus on your audience and if
you made it this far in a video and
you're still watching and you commit you
promise to take action after watching
this I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believe in the comments as well
you want to hammer your message hammer
it I want you to beat it to death
like knock on the door over and over and
over again repeatedly beat that message
to death so if I have one message I'm
just gonna beat it to death I'm gonna
every five or six minutes I'm gonna come
back and say look I'm here to teach
about how to dominate your competition
five minutes later I'm showing you how
to dominate your competition just hammer
it to death I was at Google this week
and they were like dude you got a lot of
self-confidence you don't know that you
don't know if I'm self-confident no one
knows about my self-confidence how would
you you know I appear self-confident to
you but you don't know if I am or not
see that's the difference conviction and
authority
if you want to learn the 10 Universal
skills that are hard to learn that will
pay off forever check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there every morning I go for a run
that's the first thing I do every
morning haven't taken a day off of
running since December 2016